hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to within deep sorrows
I can understand why it's deep sorrows
because you're so sorrowful that you're
trapped here that you want to kill
yourself there's something like that
don't know why we came off one of the
biggest jumps girls I've ever faced
I knew something was gonna happen but
just know I've been stayin while you're
talking about I ready my dozen here you
got to begin me what the hell I mean see
what I'm gonna do
well you made I've been seen you can
read what he's supposed to do and have a
flashlight it doesn't work anymore well
alright then I'll just go about my day
bloody freakin dah this is the best ever
I love it good death am I supposed to do
I need to find some way to turn off the
gas
I want to go down there jab
yes seriously okay no I don't think I'm
supposed to go that way
ah think I'm so Co that way maybe I need
to go back and try to find some way of
turning off the gas so I can move
upstairs what's the point of even going
into those bathrooms hang on wait let me
double check I never like I never like
press the use button for a key or
something
uh-huh I was a little too concerned at
what happened to me um how I died oh
okay bomb spamming the use button
picking up aha I knew there had to be
something okay one key oh I get it
it was like it was like a game what's
behind door number one and I picked the
wrong door okay so I have a key now
where can I use it that is the question
a key to one key to one I'm a feeling
this is the door back here on the left
oh hey I was seen by some dumbest Tommy
okay there's like all right ha ha ha ha
what the hell okay
open up open up oh I win dark Oh God
and I go in the basement oh yes day ah
come on what can I get my friggin
flashlight but flesh that would be
delightful right now
whoo I can't see anything I'm repressing
II on what what I get what did I do
oh okay all right then
that would have been nice if I could
have seen that could but still don't
know what it means that I have been seen
oh good oh good oh good for you
come on I bring it off
okay that's how you're gonna be huh are
you gonna be nice gonna be what did i do
I did some kind my flashlight back not
that I think it'll help but what
happened what happened what primary
colors yellow plus blue equals green
blue plus red equals purple paintbrush
plus water equals purple I don't know
what you're doing are you talking about
it's important for me I'll learn that in
like third grade okay
though I did some I pressed the button
on the thingy I'm assuming that doing
that did something you know find the
diary and burn it to ashes who are you
to tell me to do such an atrocious thing
okay
that was really clever the way they used
to shadow to make me turn around just in
time to see it disappear I gotta say I
applaud its effort at dickory when's the
2013 Vickery award pardon would say
we'll run that by me again you wanna say
that one more time say that to my face
maybe
and I'm my fireside back I like my plan
lay back ain't no going that way good I
didn't I didn't want to go that way okay
what does that tell me oh no you don't
know you know you're back off you all
right yeah you should've stopped it No
up up down down in there and right back
up
oh look I can't go back now wait weren't
there stairs here where's their stairs
here oh pretty sure there were stairs
here there's leading up like this way
maybe aah
and there were stairs shouldn't I have a
flashlight you took away my flashlight
Ike what is this a carnival exit really
know what you're talking about
who's going on oh I'm just walking in
the darkness why don't I have a violet
why did you take away my flesh
who's that sound what's with the thumpy
thump I'm not going towards there screw
you can I jump just a little bit
how about a Jew nope only can't make it
across this insurmountable chasm alright
I'll play your game let's go to exit God
[ __ ] Bagon asses
oh god damn it
no you don't what the hell am i walking
into
uh uh uh uh ain't no way we're am I
going I'm I don't see anything now what
am i doing I'm in complete darkness I
don't have a line line he what excuse me
what happened where am I
I don't know was that sound I can't
stand another thing I don't think I
supposed to be here I know what happened
but oh what's going on
am I still playing the game correctly
because I seem to be a bit lost in the
dark I really think that I'm I'm
supposed to have a flashlight at this
point it was very weird that I don't
have that
I hear things I don't know what I'm
supposed to do I really think I'm
supposed to have a flashlight at this
point hang on I got a I don't know what
I'm doing I don't want to go back to the
menu in case I all wait no Oh apparently
I can't resume all right then I'll be
back as soon as I figure this out what
the hell all right guys I'm generally
back to where I was before apparently I
did that all for nothing because it took
my flashlight if way again so I'm
guessing that's just what's supposed to
happen so I'm not gonna go wandering off
into the darkness this time oh hi hi I
gotta tell ya playing this game without
talking not always fun
who's that whoa ah I was posed to go
over here and stick a frickin lightbulb
into my flashlight what the hell it
turned it into a magic wand oh okay so
I'm good sorry I was just too dumb to
realize that I was supposed to go
towards the light but again that would
be very easy to miss some things in this
game are quite obvious oh that lovely
now those drawings in the thing have
never mind you know what never mind I
have it let's just go
budding got Angua below ding ding okay
so going upstairs into what what is that
key to the thing to the switch to the
thing was that telling me who I was
supposed to do before or what I already
did most of what I just said meant the
same thing
walking into darkness
hello yeah going through the beginning
of the game again with today
I also thing going through the beginning
of the game again with no sound was very
disconcerting this game has got some
feel to it oh boy the music room my old
home how relaxing right okay thing else
dear but is that something in the
background I hear that where am I going
I don't know what I'm doing great
excuse me you won't run that by me again
would you call me hello
this lesson will never end well not of
you're just at this level of math that's
pathetic
oh that's what I heard before did I
somehow stumble in the dark all the way
over here buying exams also I did not
open the middle stall this time whoa
okay this is what I heard before but I
didn't know what was going on
oh I fight a walked in here I would have
seen this but it still wouldn't help me
because I was way behind way behind
didn't even have the flashlight light
okay what am i doing is this for
anything
their purpose is a point to this push
them I just walk it oh that is a lovely
painting holy crap
all right I don't think I was supposed
to go this way I missed a jump scare the
clown whatever period no that was
painting the clown I don't know what the
thing is that popped up yeah yeah oh
that was the thing oh there's the egg
stein right there okay
oh thank you shut up [ __ ]
pressing e job what do you want from me
where am I supposed to be what am I
supposed to see here wish I was watching
Glee what do I miss I missed something I
need something to bridge the gap so that
I can cross
I need like a big plank of wood
something like huh
I don't know if I'm supposed to find
something in these classrooms there's a
whole lot of nothing why is it always
like schools and there's three hospitals
in it really nice kid stuff that it's
always awful and horrible I mean I would
think that there's something to this but
I don't know
I guess it's nothing I'm guessing it's
nothing also I found out how to run its
Q and it's like it's got a long cooldown
or something
last me I don't know hmmm I'm making the
loop back again but I don't know I don't
think there was anything that I missed I
went in every single one of these rooms
no no and no no no and holy no can't
find anything nothing at all nothing
that I miss is there on that breathing
that disturbed me at first but that's me
after I'm out of breath cuz apparently I
can only run for like two steps at a
time I already played that Oh what where
was that
are you kidding me where the hell was
that how was I supposed to find that
good god are you joking that would have
been impossible that was just by sheer
luck that I found that oh I'm just gonna
start spamming my used button wherever I
go hope right Aisha
that's something will fall into my lap
hello baby
it was that oh no that's the same thing
I don't know what this symbol means I
don't know where this key goes but I'm
guessing it's that door that I could
press use on but it didn't quite open
I'm guessing it's another way around yep
okay Oh cuz they are room I do love the
creative arts
okay upper arm muscles still life
drawing huh we got Barker's diary it's
just a thing I put the burn how and
where I I don't exactly know but I'm
assuming something's gonna try to stop
me
oh yeah jump yes jumped up would be a
good idea right now down down and out Oh
slow motion jumper that's how it's gonna
be
oh come on you're pathetic
oh hi my run
what but okay
where am I oh wait are back in the
beginning
ah that was the end okay well then I
just stick this on to the last episode
so everyone ignore that I don't know
what the hell happened there uh-huh
uh-huh I was really good it was really
good
although I have to admit I was hoping
for it felt like he was building up to
something and that was the big
anti-climactic I wish they had done more
stuff with whatever the hell that
monster was cuz it was really cool with
the way they were trying to play with me
a little bit here and there but it
wasn't bad it was really good I enjoyed
that thoroughly I mean there's a lot of
potential here who is devily ambience
for to it so I was enjoying that it was
just a bit not enough at the end there I
wish there'd a bit more but it's good to
want more I mean it's good that the game
goes like I wanted to play more but
either way that was awesome that was
sincerely awesome I broke my flow a bit
thereby having to go back through the
whole game again but either way that was
a lot of fun so thank you all so much
for watching click the link in the
description so that you can play the
game for yourself and support the
developers thank you guys get in as
always I will see you in the neck
ah
Kludd
is that burglar